hey guys it is the 8th of January my
name is just McDonald and you're tuned
into gamespot news I have a little bit
sick today so do please excuse my weird
perky voice let's beam use the stuff
stone you've eckerd many of your
sentiments on the so called console war
by saying they're not interested in
comparing their data against competitors
marketing VP John Kohler has said that
he thinks that growing the ps4 install
base is far more important than
comparing ps4 and xbox one sales Colin
told CVG the numbers are only really
significant in helping sony push toward
their goal of bringing more players onto
the system and encouraging publishers
and devs to keep bringing great games to
play stations do you guys agree with
this way of thinking and how much do you
think Sony or Microsoft is really
bothered by the other company's
performance let me know in disappointing
but still relatively unsurprising use
the tradition of publishers deciding not
to bring their games to the wii u is
continuing with alien isolation sega
have said that they have no plans to
carry the game to the console but gave
no indication as to why although one
could suspect it's probably due to some
of the same reasons that nobody else is
bringing their games to the wii u that
was set to be a wii u version of aliens
colonial marines but after critics and
gamers alike agreed that they pretty
much hated the game the production of
this version was ultimately cancelled
are you guys all right with this one
skipping the wii u or not last up
titanfall news is here and respawn have
confirmed the play account for the
multiplayer human robot shoot-'em-up
each match is set to feature a maximum
of twelve human players or six players
aside respawns vince zampella has said
that the count has been tuned as a
result of gameplay and balancing AI and
not due to any technical limitations
while some gamers have been upset by the
confirmation Zampella has clarified that
the number reflects humans only and
there can be loads of AI the obvious
example being ty Lee's each team will be
padded out with AI so human players can
get themselves points off of soldiers
who are a little less challenging than
their human counterparts do you think 12
human players is a good way to go or
you hoping for something different out
of titan forum you can let me know in
the comments down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at Jess McDonald so most of
the things that I found interesting from
today and we are slowly weaning
ourselves off of those next gen console
sales story so hopefully you can put
down your pitchforks I'm just mcdonald
and i'll be back with a bunch more news
tomorrow